what's going on guys we've got a very
special guest today so why don't we get
right to it he is a groundbreaking
stand-up comedian a New York Times
bestselling author and a nerd of the
highest order
Patton Oswalt thank you for being here
thank you for having me so you've got a
brand new book out silver screen themed
learning about life from an addiction to
film this is available in stores now
Amazon
Patton Oswalt commie and find it
everywhere right yes so we're gonna talk
all about this but you had a reason you
came down here today you'd something
very you're very passionate about well I
mean you know every every movie buff has
movies where oh why couldn't the story
have continued why can't we see more of
that world and and as much as I'm
philosophically against just spitting
out sequels because something is
successful I do firmly firmly believe
that M night Shyamalan film unbreakable
not only deserves a sequel deserves to
be a trilogy and that this is a perfect
forum to talk about it because we have a
segment that we've done before called
dream sequel oh good okay good good yes
yeah so patent tell us what you like
about unbreakable Bruce Willis plays a
guy who is unbreakable he does not get
sick his bones not break he cannot be
harmed Samuel Jackson plays his mentor
slash best friend plays his obi-wan
basically and yet at the end of the
movie reveals that he was the arch
villain all along and he has a he's on
the other end of the spectrum for Bruce
Willis character his bones are extremely
brittle they break easily
osteogenesis imperfecta is what he oh
yeah pull and hey yeah so his bones
break almost like that yeah kids
nicknamed him michelin mr. glass which
is at the end he was like that's how I
know now you are the hero and I am the
villain yeah because the kids call me
mr. glass which is a perfect villain
name now here's what k here are the
things that drive me crazy about the
movie in a good way and why I demand a
sequel a couple of things missing and a
couple of tantalizing things that would
make both sequels amazing yeah right
there are two great movies to come out
number one by the way you're giving us
more than the price of admission because
you're giving us the dream trilogy yeah
and I'm giving you the dream total
change the name please I mean is really
in trilogy thank you if you notice at
the end in the end scene when Bruce
Willis goes and confronts samuel
l.jackson and jackson reveals who he is
the whole time that I'm the guy and
there's books on chemistry and
explosives and engineering and
architecture everything that a super
villain would study to engineer massive
disasters yeah and there's clippings on
the wall well okay there's our first
clue if you note if you look at the
clippings closely yes um some of them
are you know horrible disaster thousands
dead some of them say infant sole
survivor of stadium collapse teen sole
survivor of mudslide there are other
unbreakable zs-- in the world and he has
been putting together a dossier on all
of them and now Bruce Willis has those
he should start recruiting a Justice
League of him on branch axon was like
some weird bizarro Nick Fury he was a
bizarre he was a bizarro Nick Fury thank
you did I even think about that he was a
bizarro Nick Fury so there are other
unbreakable zhh in the world so that the
second movie should be Bruce Willis
embracing his hero status starting to
spread the gospel a little bit but then
at the end of the movie he should at the
end of the second one do it the same
ending his empire where things are not
great and either his gets either his kid
gets hurt who's not unbreakable or his
wife leaves him or he gets one of these
young unbreakable 'he's killed gosh and
then in the third movie what has been
going on the whole time keep in mind the
last frame of unbreakable is Sam
Jackson's character smiling maniacally
yeah I know what I am now and it says
elijah glass is in an Institute for the
criminally insane now he's been sitting
there the whole time watching what he
has wrought he's watching Bruce Willis's
character david dunn do all this if he
knows what's going on if you're studying
how to build bombs how to derail trains
how to blow
damns you've met others supervillain
type people in the world you have a you
have a network now of people that can
then get you out of your answer the
third movie is him now getting out the
first thing Elijah would do is make
David Dunn seem like a villain and then
Bruce Willis's character has to now
fight to regain what's actually good
about himself and put down Elijah once
and for all and the other thing that he
would do in the third movie and this is
one one element that was missing from
unbreakable and then maybe they cut it
for time or whatever in the movie and if
you know there's a line where he where
Sam Jackson says my blood lacks a
protein where I can't heal or form
strong bones it would be interesting if
in the third movie one of Sam Jackson's
plans is to capture David Dunn and get a
blood transfusion and become unbreakable
himself with his evil genius mind that's
the ultimate nightmare is if the arch
villain gets control of whatever the
superpower is let's keep going with this
dream aspect who would you want to see
in it who would you want it direct well
I would okay
I would I would like M night Shyamalan
to direct it could you repeat that you
said you want M night Shyamalan still to
direct it I'd yes I do
or you can read that out in a court of
law dude all right it's your dream and
then as far as the people that are you
know uh that would play the other
unbreakable oh the Iranian walls I would
just I mean there are so many amazing
actors and actresses that are coming up
I would almost want it to be people that
are totally unknown people that I see
doing stuff on the internet right now
some of the people host of screen
junkies and that's you you no offense
you would be really cool as part of the
network of villains oh yeah of the guy
that he was either the computer hacker
or the look I used to work for water and
power they me over so hard I know the
three valve to hit on that dam it'll
wipe out this whole valley just swapping
right back
oh no yeah and I think Robin Wright
should be a huge factor in the second
movie because she is she's the one the
first one that would see him kind of
getting into his head a little bit so
these two sequels I want you to give us
titles and are there any tagline
possibly Bruce Willis and voiceover he's
talking to five different people and
then we put the same title unbreakable
up and then we just add an S to the end
he goes are you ready for the truth um
and then the third one the third trailer
would be Sam Jackson voiceover we just
hear his voice and then the title comes
up same but it just says broken ah and
that's your third one dude
Patton I don't know if you realized but
we are going to throw to that trailer
right now you know what the scariest
thing is to not know your place in this
world
to not know why you're here
you're the Rainmaker legend is a
Rainmaker came out of nowhere
these are mediocre times mister it's
hard for many to believe they're
extraordinary things inside themselves
as well as others
you are not a freak don't you believe
anybody that tries to convince you that
you have to go through your life
believing that so many sacrifices just
define you a person put here to protect
the rest of us now that we know who you
are I know who I am I don't wanna play
this game
let's take a look at your life are you
ready Wow ah mind-blowing now I want to
see those right now you have to hear
singers make them yeah em or is it night
whatever
hashtag unbreak is hashtag unbreakable
to make it Patton Oswalt's new book
silver screen fiend learning about life
from an addiction to film he's not just
a film lover he's a film addict you had
a serious problem and this problem about
the time in your life book is a memoir
and it's a warning if you're a film fan
or even at all interested in movies pick
up this book um and what would your
dream sequel be tell us the plot who
you'd like to have in it let us know in
the comments section below best answer
um we're gonna send you a signed copy of
this book uh that's pretty sweet yeah I
got to thank this guy Patton Oswalt and
know much we have so many questions for
you will you come back and join us for a
second episode hell yeah Oh boom do it
yeah um tune in for our next Patton
Oswalt episode where we're gonna ask him
of his thoughts about Marvel DC Universe
also I'm gonna need a drink I'll be
right back
oh yeah I want to thank you for watching
I wanna thank again Patton Oswalt uh hit
me up on Twitter I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye
twenty years later they're back but this
time we are bringing the fight to them
and in space everyone can hear freedom
ring